more scenes of carnage in ukraine as
russian forces inch closer to the center
of the capital of kiev air raid sirens
sounding moments ago while gunfire and
explosions are being heard throughout
the day
u.s officials warning that the key city
could fall by this weekend
but the ukrainians are putting up a
fight russia facing more resistance than
thought
ukrainian citizens taking up arms and
are encouraged to make molotov cocktails
president zielinski who says he is
target number one of the russians
is out in the streets and posting this
defiant video warning putin that they
will defend their independence
trey yingst is reporting live from the
ukrainian capital of kiev trey
jesse you can hear the sirens behind me
the capital of ukraine is currently
under attack ukrainian forces tell us
that there are russian troops inside the
city limits at this hour we have heard
explosions in the distance all evening
and those air raid sirens that you just
heard there going off throughout the
night most of the civilian population in
bomb shelters or underground we were in
a metro today here in the ukrainian
capital of kiev
and we spoke with the civilians who are
terrified they have heard this siren
before over the past 36 hours and it is
often followed by a russian air campaign
targeting infrastructure on the northern
part of the city this is significant as
these russian forces look to make an
offensive toward the capital of kiev but
we do know it's not only the ukrainian
army looking to fight back but also
civilians we spoke with one member of
parliament today who told us that he
picked up a weapon from a local police
station he said they were handing them
out like candy the ukrainian government
calling on civilians to pick up arms and
help the army to push back those russian
troops jesse so
you said that russian forces have
officially entered the city
are they going in shooting or are they
going in as more saboteurs to soften
things up for the larger invasion
we've heard reports of sabotage
operations actually president zielinski
of ukraine spoke about this and warned
citizens today against speaking with
people who look like they might be
suspicious and remember there is a
martial law curfew in place right now
and it's just after midnight here in
kiev so there's no one on the streets
except for police officers and emergency
personnel
the thing to also remember is that the
civilian population here is quite
worried about this moving forward so
they are preparing for the worst and
many of them are willing to take up arms
to fight back jesse okay you want to
take it around the table judge jeanine
you know trey today we heard from
general keane and general petraeus and
and each of them talked about the fact
that
uh
putin hasn't destroyed the airfield or
taken down the infrastructure and yet
there's another school of thought and
i'm curious as to what you think and
what people are thinking on the ground
that he is specifically not targeting
the infrastructure so that he can
um control it when he gets in he wants
to be able to have an infrastructure
absolutely he is looking to replace the
government here he wants ukraine to be a
puppet country much like belarus is for
the russian government in moscow so it
wouldn't make sense for him to destroy a
lot of the infrastructure across the
city some people did worry early on that
would be the case a lot of the western
intelligence analysis was that he would
target big government buildings in the
capital we have not seen that so far
it's not to say that it will not happen
but he is looking to replace the
government and be in control of this
capital city but this country as a whole
so in other parts of ukraine we saw a
similar
event unfolding where russian troops
came in on the ground there was an air
campaign as part of it in cities like
kharkiv the second largest city in
ukraine but we did not see that massive
shock in all campaign that many were
worried about going into this and as it
started just a day and a half ago back
to you so that trey just a follow-up so
that the the thinking that you know the
russians aren't coming in as quickly or
or succeeding as quickly as they they
people think they should may really be
based upon the fact that they're trying
to preserve as much as they can of the
infrastructure while still going in and
taking over the major cities there
i think it's also based on the fact that
the ukrainian army put up such a fight
early on they have been taking
significant losses and the casualty
numbers that we have are not up to date
it's very difficult to get accurate
numbers from either side in this
conflict but they have been successful
we know in some parts of the country
with those javelin anti-tank missiles
and they've also been successful in
shooting down aircraft using air defense
systems so
the russians have faced fierce
resistance and there is a firm
understanding that if they try to make
it further into the capital city again
they will take fire not only from the
army but also from civilians who have
picked up weapons and i think moving
forward that's the thing to look at here
how this battlefield will change if they
do enter kiev they have been fighting a
lot on the outskirts of cities and
they've been targeting military
installations from the air if they get
into this urban warfare situation you
will see things that look much like
guerrilla warfare where there are
surprise attacks and ambushes on these
troops and that will look very different
it will be quite bloody and it will
consume this city if that does take
place
ukrainian forces on the outskirts of the
capital are hoping that they are able to
hold off the russian troops before it
even gets there trey what does that look
like right now that expectation of
guerrilla warfare is accompanied by your
reports of them handing out kalashnikovs
breaking the age limits potentially 14
year olds out there carrying aks but
right now as you talk about people
hunkering down some in the subway
systems i'm sure many in their homes
what does that look like is everybody
carrying a rifle around is everybody
barricading into their homes are they
preparing to engage in a firefight
we drove through the streets of kiev
today to speak with civilians and there
weren't many out on the streets many
were underground where we talked to them
in the metro system but when we drove by
government buildings you saw police
forces and even officials who wouldn't
normally be guarding a building in the
downtown area outside holding weapons
they were bracing for this to take place
and they still are at this hour this
could be hours away and the white house
washington officials in the united
states believe that kiev will indeed
fall in a matter of days it's a real
possibility
but what we saw was a population today
that was scared but also others who were
preparing we spoke with one man and he
came up to us speaking in english and he
told us he was an english teacher and
i'm going to give you his words here
because they were quite jarring but it
gives you a sense of how tense this
situation is he said to me i'm not very
well versed in weapons he said but i
will use my kitchen knife and i will
slaughter those russian pigs if they
enter this city and i'm paraphrasing
here but those were his words calling
the russians pigs and saying he would
kill them with a knife
and that is how tense things are and how
much of a resistance that we do expect
to see here in the capital of kiev if
those russian forces enter people want
the russians out of this country they
see this invasion as a clear violation
of ukrainian sovereignty and civilians
and soldiers alike say they will do
everything they can to prevent it from
going any further
fort junior if we'd only had partners
like this in afghanistan but trey just
real quickly
do you have a sense if there are there
any other weaponry coming in to ukraine
any other country providing that uh not
not just for individuals individual
citizens but for the ukrainian army
so before this offensive by the russians
took place we saw planes landing every
day some from the united states some
from lithuania the weapons were coming
from nato members and allies of the
ukrainians delivering those anti-tank
missiles that was really the biggest
request
that the ukrainian military had
understanding that
this would be an offensive that included
many many russian tanks
but in recent days there's been
conversations taking place here in the
capital about how more weapons could get
into the country there's nothing flying
in right now because the airspace is
totally closed down so there is a
possibility to move weapons in over the
borders but today we saw the nato
secretary general jen stoltenberg
basically say that nato will commit
anti-aircraft batteries to this country
but that does raise the big question how
are they going to get them here and can
they get them here in time there are
still russian air campaigns taking place
against this country as we speak and
quite frankly ukraine is running out of
time they don't have a month to wait
yesterday at the white house president
biden announced these sanctions to try
to pressure president putin to change
his behavior and pull back these forces
out of a sovereign country and he said
basically they want to wait one month to
see if they're going to do any good the
ukrainians don't have a month they don't
have 30 days they do not have 30 minutes
this offensive is currently taking place
in their capital city and people are
dying quick follow-ups casualties and
coverage do we have a sense of the
casualties on the russian side and what
coverage how what what extensive
coverage or any coverage are the
ukrainians getting of what's happening
on the ground there and maybe even
what's happening on the ground in russia
as we're seeing now that there may be
some pushback amongst russian sedentary
against
vladimir putin
the ukrainians are aware of these
anti-war protests that are taking place
in russia more than 54 cities yesterday
had demonstrators who many were detained
more than 1700 demonstrators
being taken
into custody because they were trying to
tell their government not to go to war
not to do what they are doing right now
and so they see that solidarity and they
are very aware of what's happening in
this country one thing to note though
for the entire world and also for the
ukrainian people who are watching this
unfold
this is war and it is so graphic and
bloody taking place outside of the city
and on the outskirts of the capitol
the images that you see online that
cannot be shown on television because
they are just too gory and graphic
show that a war is taking place
very much like previous land wars in
europe
bodies in the streets and tanks and
artillery being targeted from the air
it is
quite difficult for the ukrainian people
to just fully grasp what is happening
but they understand
that their people are at risk they
understand that if they do not fight
back many of them will be slaughtered
and
that is why there is so much pressure
right now in the international community
to do something and if they don't act
soon enough and it may already be too
late more people in this country will
die as a result of this russian
offensive
well that that's obviously one of the
problems because it is taken so long to
get these missiles uh into ukraine and
now there's sort of a panic to get them
more so that they can have some better
anti-aircraft defense there are reports
that a couple of days ago president
biden approved the
shipments through latvia of stingers and
that that would be an effective weapon
for the ukraine to have in their hands
it's proven to be effective against
russian
russian air power in the past have you
heard anything about that is there any
indication that they could get them in
through poland perhaps
we saw those reports as well and they
would be
definitely used based on the satellite
images that we saw today released by
maxart technologies indicating that the
russians have moved more attack
helicopters within 20 miles of the
ukrainian border
just yesterday they used similar
helicopters in an effort to take over an
airfield about 40 minutes from where we
are right now
they really just stormed the airfield
with what residents in that area
described as locusts
targeting this ukrainian military
institution because it really is an
institution it is basically the one air
base near this capital city that could
give the russians a strategic advantage
in launching a larger offensive against
the ukrainian capital it would give them
the ability to land heavy aircraft with
more soldiers and more equipment that
they could use in a ground offensive to
take over the ukrainian capital i do
want to get back to that one other
question about the casualty numbers i've
been personally avoiding the numbers and
reporting them on air simply because i
cannot independently verify them and
there is clearly a lot of gray area and
even propaganda going on amid war that's
very common during conflict both sides
want to talk about the numbers of people
who they have killed
and i think it's very important that we
are careful with the numbers because
they can often be
misconstrued during conflict back to you
thanks so much trey
well
my concern after hearing that report is
that the united states and nato did not
have enough weapons and supplies
pre-positioned
to flood the zone immediately to the
ukrainians to the military to the
ukraine citizens
to give them a little boost out of the
gate
because it seems like it might be a
little too late at this point do you
share that concern
yeah i i share that concern although we
do have the reports of rifles being
handed out to the citizenry as well look
i think the story right now in this very
moment is the resolve of the ukrainian
people harold you asked about the
messages they're getting the media
they're getting surely they're hearing
stories of what happened on snake island
with jesse you invoked the alamo
yesterday it's almost a literal
replication of the alamo in those those
forces taking on the russian navy or the
ghost of kiev we're hearing about this
ace pilot that took down maybe five
russian fighters on his own these are
the the the soldier who sacrificed his
life to take out a bridge the ukrainian
soldier who died in that operation these
have to be inspirational then when i
hear trey say i'm ready to use my
kitchen knife it's both inspirational
and it's also terrifying of where this
can and probably will go on the streets
of kiev i got to sense martha that if it
is a slaughter in the capital and the
russians do eventually overrun the
entire country the ukrainians are never
going to forgive the west they will
never forgive us they wanted more they
wanted more help they wanted stiffer
sanctions they want to throw up a no-fly
zone right now and if if that doesn't
happen how how terrible will that be
well i think there's a history of
presidents and leaders who will have um
who will have this on their conscience
to be quite honest we encouraged ukraine
to give up their nuclear weapons we told
them that we would have their back uh
that was part of that whole arrangement
you go back to president obama who sent
them meals ready to eat uh when they
were trying to overthrow a
russian puppet regime that was in
control of the country they successfully
did that anyway um it's an extraordinary
legacy there's a reason why this country
is always in the news because it is so
symbolic for vladimir putin he wants it
back he is humiliated by the fact that
he has seen his own guy kicked out and
you know yushenko brought in um who had
been poisoned by uh by the kgb with
agent orange um it's it's extraordinary
and you look at this young president
right who is just
i mean it's a crazy story right he was
on tv he was a comedian he played a
principal who becomes president of the
country
and now he's president of the country
and so there was this i think
lightweight feeling about what he might
be like look at this guy
i mean he is a portrait of courage he's
extraordinary he's standing on the
street he said you know i'm not running
you know i'm not ashav ghani i'm not
taking off with my money in a helicopter
i'm staying in my country that i love
and i'm asking begging really for
support from nato for support from the
united states and now it's like oh we're
going to try to rush stuff in at the
last minute as if we didn't know this
was coming um he's he's really an
incredible story i hope to god that he
can hang on who knows what's going to
happen for him he called himself and his
family target number one and target
number two and boy when don't you know
that vladimir putin would love to crush
this guy oh absolutely um but but i i
give him all the credit in the world
he's really inspiring yeah he is and
here he is right here uh he vows to
defend the country let's listen
the president is here we are all here
our soldiers are here the citizens are
here and we are here we defend our
independence that's how it'll go
i think it was you mentioned afghanistan
i believe it was the afghan president
that flew out of the country
the minute things got a little hot
when the taliban was taking over this
guy's staying harold ford jr
striking to me is the purpose and the
resistance and the ownership the
ukrainian scene may have of their land
and their future and they're going to
live or die
on that mantle
i mentioned only as we all know i mean
if we literally had 10 of this medal in
afghanistan
with with those troops we spent as
american citizens billions tens of
billions of dollars training it might
have been a different outcome but let's
look forward i look at this a little
differently than some around the table
there's no doubt we can go back and look
at everybody from reagan
to george h.w bush
to obama to trump uh to clinton and
others to to how we may have behaved
differently uh we probably should have
advanced more weapons uh as we think as
we see things now but remember had we
done that we would we would have owned
this even more number two i'm 51 i
served in congress from 26 years old at
36 years old and in my lifetime as an
american i've never seen a more
compelling case for america to send
troops now i'm not saying we should but
in iraq we never had this kind of
evidence to say we should send troops to
defend our injury this guy is trying to
undo the architecture that we spent
trillions of dollars building after
world war ii and obviously throughout
the cold war he has made clear he wants
to reassemble everything he had before
1994. number three we probably hope we
don't send troops there if we're going
to do anything i think we should send to
our nato to our nato partners in the
event that he does take ukraine in the
event that he does try to encroach
across another border but what heartens
me the most is what you said from the
outset and what we're all saying
the kind of resistance these people are
showing this is what freedom-loving
people do
when someone tries to take their freedom
away we have won in many ways because
it's our ideas that putin is that putin
is really going against he's afraid of
this country because he thinks they may
join nato and may join the eu he's
afraid of this country because he can't
believe they don't want to come running
back to him so in so many ways we should
celebrate the beauty and the majesty of
freedom are there things we should have
done differently there's no question but
i got to tell you i hope we're able to
find ways to advance weapons to these
people because their metal their courage
uh you don't see things like this and
those of us who love civics and love the
country we ought to be watching this and
learning lessons from these people yeah
judge when you get a taste of freedom as
a free people in that country and they
try to take it away from you
two decades later this is putin now
trying to yeah that's you're gonna fight
to the death we are watching history
repeat itself
what we're seeing today is president
zielinski who put it right on the table
when he said quote the world's most
powerful forces are watching from afar
and putin's ego must be so inflated
because he's got the western world bowed
down
as he as a political thug goes in to
attack a sovereign nation and the west
is just kind of like oh i don't know
what we'll do maybe we'll sanction this
maybe we'll sanction that and the truth
is
this isn't a movie
it looks like a movie but these are real
people who are dying these are real
people who have been begging us as we
watch them line up the troops and the
tanks and the blood and the temporary
hospitals and every day we saw what they
were
what they were getting ready to do and i
get that zielinski didn't want to panic
his people i get that he didn't tell
them you know it's time to get out but
right now this is about raw power it's
not about religion it's not about people
who hate each other it's about a a thug
who wants the russian empire back and
you know what the idea that the united
states is today buying 500 000 barrels
of oil from this thug and allowing him
to make money that allows him then to
fight this war is disgusting and i'm
going to add one more thing i got to
keep going hang on the bottom line is
that biden doesn't want to disrupt the
the russian energy exports and we could
have done it with the keystone pipeline
and this is all a setup and he's talking
about he doesn't want the americans to
suffer in the end the americans are
suffering and the ukrainians are
suffering everybody's suffering hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else